sure looks like the big guy got his 10%
Republicans giving folks what they say
is the clearest evidence yet between Joe
Biden's bank account and Hunter cash
flow from China specifically in the form
of this very here check made out to Joe
Biden for 40 Grand from his brother's
wife James comr says that do could be
traced directly back to the
commies we've already proven that he met
with all the people that send his family
money we we've proven that Joe Biden's
lied countless times to American people
but his knowledge and involvement of his
family Shady business dealings we've
proven the family had over 20 shell
companies we had proven they've had all
these bank accounts now we have enough
bank accounts in Johan where we can
actually trace the money back to the
source so we found the check to Joe
Biden this is the second check in a week
the first one was for 200,000 this one
was for 40,000 but what's what's most
alarming about this $40,000 check it
traces directly back to China the GOP
breaking down the tangled web of money
transfers that it all starts with China
wiring Hunter's company 5 million out of
that cut hunter gets 400,000 do the math
40 grand out of
400,000 10% for the big guy pretty
simple but Democrats have a simpler
explanation two brothers loan each other
money they pay it back not an office end
of story no evidence we're back to the
same thing listen James this is your
friend Jared talking to you don't make
me continue to embarrass you in
committee I actually feel bad when I
make you look like a fool because I'm
just exposing what you're
doing so Harold the dem's excuse Bros
being Bros here's 40K here's 200k sure
it's traced back to China but that's
what Bros do they also got 200 shell
companies what family doesn't have 200
shell campanies after all they have a
beach house you need the
shells at this point Harold isn't it
time to stop carrying water for the most
corrupt in uh Administration in the
history of this
country the um no answer Israel is under
Tech Ukraine needs money and these guys
I I felt bad for Mike Johnson who I
don't agree with him on a lot of things
but I thought he gave a really really
good first day speech and I think he's
trying his hard as a manager group of
guys manag men and women there I think
Jared mosit who we've had on the show we
showed him on the show in the last
several days talking about Israel and we
were in agreement with him I don't know
where the evidence is this is this is
not how I would necessarily do business
I don't I I when I hope I don't ilend to
do business in China but he was not in
office if the the check set loan
repayment who are we to believe um James
Cola or them so I'm more focused on
Israel and Ukraine ah nice deflection Mr
Ford Jr so Brian uh I guess China to the
bidens is actually a Chinese Laundry
right you could say that absolutely very
clever I know you did if you put bring a
showell company to your ear can you hear
the ocean I'm just wondering okay fin I
just want to continue to work that's a
good Fox and Friends question thank you
very much am I the first one ever to be
in the recipient of a Dana Pino Heckle
this is unbelievable all right make it
easy I know it's okay know what bothers
me most about this what the dealings
they do with the c
CFC company is funding the belt and Road
program which was derived and created
just to undermine American influence in
these developing areas and it's worked
they just had a major conference again
yeah it's been ineffective in some
places but there it was created to
undermine American leadership everywhere
and he had no problem sleeping at night
investing in this company and also in
this story they talk about Hunter uh
editorial today coming out saying
everyone's Jumping All Over Me
humiliating me because of my addiction
last time nobody cares about your
addiction it's about why your dad would
put you out in high stakes international
business under different pseudo names
and put put you there to finance the
entire family knowing you walk the tight
RPP every single day of emotional
balance nobody cares about your
addiction it's what you were up to and
if someone would be transparent James
comr wouldn't have to go through this I
love that he says that it's only because
he's the son of the president if we if
he wasn't he'd probably be in jail Katie
yeah the headline I think we Hunter
Biden I fought to get sober political
weaponization of my addiction hurts more
than me is he using this as a cover or a
def much like Harold they have put yeah
they have put story after story after
Story out about Hunter Biden's addiction
because they want to use it to distract
away from the family business that Joe
Biden said never existed you know let's
just hold Joe Biden to his own standard
of what he said he said I was never in I
never spoke to my son about his business
dealings find out that's not true
through lots of different evidence then
he changes the story and says I was
never in business with my son then he
says show me the money find me the money
show me the money they find all these
checks so if you ask the question about
who should be believed here Joe Biden
has set himself up to be disproven
knowing what he knows about the family
business so I don't think holding him to
his own standard and holding Hunter to
the standard uh that they have set for
themselves is anything but following
where they've told them to go yeah I
know it sounds TR Dana but I'm going to
say it If This Were Republican holy hell
on a pancake exactly on a pancake and
pancakes can be delicious but also
fattening so you don't anyway um okay
this a couple things I was thinking um I
don't even know how to use venmo okay I
don't have a venmo account yet I'm
working on it Peter if you could help me
because I understand that it's helpful
but to me this seems like a very strange
family yeah who is loaning all this
money to your adult siblings like we're
all adults like we yeah I mean how many
people are like I'm like hey I'm going
to lend you I'm going lend you 500,000
and then you're going to send me 40 and
then you're going to send me 10 and
you're going to send me 20 and like they
like need to have a family I it's really
kind of bizarre behavior I'm not saying
that's illegal but anyway the other
thing is not to mention sleeping with
your widow's wife but that's another
story all true yes I mean I mean who
Among Us yes okay but also here's the
thing I also want to point out I listen
to a long podcast it was very good it
was about this County in Washington
state they have a elected they have
voted for whoever has won the presidency
for like since 1980 okay none of them
ever bring up this issue when they're
unhappy with Biden they think he is too
old that's the number one thing they're
upset about inflation the border and
crime to me almost about a year out from
the 2024 election if you don't have some
like Smoking Gun that's going to tip it
all over you have all of those issues to
focus on in addition to this keep doing
your hearings whatever but this is where
Republicans can really win on those
issues maybe Joe Biden is the ancient
Chinese
secret throwback right calone calone
right can't do that commercial anymore
was thatal I think it was calonal must
take me away no no you're so you're so
young wasn't kgon ancient chci I
actually have no idea what you're
talking about no you guys I'm pretty
sure who was ringing around the C oh
that was TI it was
all right but Dana's never this is why
we're number one hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else